le cinéma avec une nouvelle adaptation
d'une bande dessinée voici le chat du
rabbin signer johan soir un plaidoyer
pour une laïcité féline et tout cela en
3d marylène bono et francis george et
les amis tout le monde aura fini ce
pourrait fermer par miss mama aussi un
chat qui parle et qui apprend les
rudiments de la religion juive un chat
amoureux de la fille du rabbin a bien si
ma maîtresse son nom on dirait une
pâtisserie au biel une drôle de fable
que joann sfar a d'abord raconté en bd
cinq tomes neuf cent mille exemplaires
vendus aujourd'hui un dessin animé en 3d
les dieux parce que si vous voulez je
peux cherche une fable qu'avec des
animaux cacher c'est une critique de la
religion et qui vient de l'intérieur qui
vient de l'intérieur de la famille c'est
peut-être un truc pour raconter que les
juifs et les arabes se ressemblent
beaucoup enfin c'est un truc comme ça
les comédiens maquillé en costume ont
d'abord interprété le rôle et
enregistrer leurs textes
après seulement les dessins ont été
réalisés sous la direction de joann sfar
maurice bénichou qui marche ou hafsia
herzi qui s'allonge quelques pas ça dit
le personnage et tout de suite ça
faisait renaître les sensations je
voulais dire avec les dessins de la bd
siècle et il fallait donner une voix aux
chats
si je suis un chat juif tu dois faire ma
part vie de femme ouais c'est moi le
chat du rabbin à la voix il nous prend
pour des demeurés c'est un chat c'est
humain quand il miaule par exemple dit
miao
heureusement que gimont tapas pour
veiller oui c'est comme une conscience
ce qu'on aurait près de soi un
personnage une conscience heureuse
malines coquine voltairienne le chat du
rabbin un dessin animé entre le roi lion
et persepolis qui dénonce avec humour et
tendresse l'utilisation de la religion à
des fins politiques